[Music]  as a team John Magaro wanted to help his  community people were damaging their  health and polluting the environment by  using kerosene lamps  there was no electricity in his village  but the Kenyan village does have ten  waterfalls nearby through force of will  and a lot of creativity John was able to  find ways to generate electricity using  hydropower his mini power station is now  quite state-of-the-art but at first John  used a bicycle rim and a conveyor belt  as part of the pumping system today John  Magaro and his team provide green  affordable energy to over 120 households  and children can now do their homework  in the evenings without harming their  health  do you like that if you are also doing  your bit tell us about it visit our  website or send us a tweet hashtag doing  your bed we hear your stories